Oh
there was a great scene in a movie about
these two brothers that wished to become
writers we start learning about the
story of their unfolding lives the drama
of their every day one of the guys falls
in love and then his girlfriend commits
suicide
something utterly tragic erupts in his
life and then the film continues and all
of a sudden there's a scene that shows
him frantically writing down and the
narrator tells us he felt guilty over
the creativity triggered by his lovers
death his notion of a tragedy and lead
to breakthrough can lead to rebirth that
the instances of suffering in our lives
can actually inspire us to make
beautiful art is a sort of paradoxical
ecstasy you know that
we can take our wounds and we can turn
them into something larger that we not
have suffered in vain is a wild idea
because it doesn't mean that we are
happy for our suffering it doesn't mean
that we wished for these tragic things
to happen to us as artists but it means
that we're able to take that aim take
that aching grab city and out put
something in the world and make a
contribution because at least that way
we validate the fact that we exist we
affirm ourselves we have no choice but
to do so in the face of entropy in the
face of death do not say that we exist
is to not live at all